[Music]
thank you first of all for for dressing
up people don't usually come on the show
wearing a tuxedo well it's not for you
gun oh oh why are you wearing a tuxedo
then Adam well as you know Conan it's
award season in Hollywood yes and so
it's good to be prepared because at any
moment I could you know be asked to
present something or get nominated for
something neither of which has happened
but what you're saying is you're wearing
this in anticipation anticipation you
would as you know you never know there's
only like a five month period every year
where Hollywood gets to you know stand
around in a circle and and like jerk
each other off so I want to be prepared
what a wonderful way to put it
I've been to that award show by the way
yeah I've been trying to get into that
one I was nominated okay well you look
fantastic I have thank you very much
it's very good and I think I saw a
picture of you at an awards show and I
want to ask you about it I think you
were presenting an award to Jessica Alba
the beautiful Jessica Alba and you're
not in a tux there but I saw this photo
and I thought I have a few questions
first of all what are you doing with
your mouth well I had a lozenge in my
mouth
that's what I know that doesn't sound
true but that's what I had a why I
believe it because you're making such an
unusual weird face that I make and you
seem to be looks like was the Taffy
award yeah and and then you're looking
at her in kind of a creepy way yeah I
mean ask about that let's see there you
are okay you look like if I was there
I'd have asked a police officer to
intervene right now I know what it looks
like but what I was actually doing is I
was looking at her but that clears this
Oh get your mind out of the gutter let's
talk about your family life you have two
kids two kids yeah kids either one has
either one shown any interest in acting
because I'm bring this up for reason I
have two very young kids and you know
sometimes are your kids my kids are in
their late 40s okay they're really young
they're very young yeah yeah because I
am over 94 right that's why no I
my kids are nine and seven okay and and
and you know sometimes I think I don't
know if I want them to go into show be
honest I mean I'm in show business but
you know I want them to be Realtors or
something what about you have they shown
any interest in show business well so
far no thank God but they also my son
seems to be mulling over different
occupations like we were at his doctor
the doctors recently and our children's
doctor does this wonderful thing that we
really appreciate his parents wear when
they ask them to take their clothing off
to be examined they make sure every time
to say to the kids look you could only
do this because I'm a doctor your
parents are in the room you never do
this for anything for his okay very
smart thing to teach the kids absolutely
but this last time my son and I went to
the doctor after he disrobe to have the
doctor examine him he asked the doctor
if he became a doctor just so he could
look at people's privates
what did the doctor say the doctor said
well no and I just immediately took out
my phone and started writing it down
because I have to write that's fantastic
so he could be he could be a comedy
writer yeah maybe or maybe he's actually
thinking like well this is something
doctors get to do they get to look at
privates whenever they want right you
let's see them yeah okay is the
interested in health or your children's
and health beyond the doctor's office at
all well they're interested in their
poop well who isn't interested in their
own food fair question right fair
question
yes and and so they are interested in
your own you might my son looks like
that both of my kids my son looked at
his poop recently and he said it looked
like an arrow shooting through a ribbon
which is crazy because it didn't look
like that at all I don't know what's
wrong with it
my daughter looked at hers and said it
looked like a snake covering a face you
know dr. Gupta is gonna be out here look
I have a lot of questions for him a
snake covering a face might mean she has
some sort of terrible disease I don't
think so no and I wouldn't go down that
road to file you I also wouldn't go in
and check it out every time they ask
them what does your poop look like yeah
it's you you're the one that comes off
as the creep in the story when I come
down to breakfast daddy's in a tuxedo
what is your poop look like